citizens of the reject Nation it is time to
go back to the dcau we think with Batman bad
blood does it have vampires does it have blood
because there's a little sharpness to that
M Batman that could be a Batman what do you
think John I'm not even seeing it because
I haven't seen it I think we got bad blood
and we used to have mad love and now we're
gonna find out what caused this for the bat
family is there a bad romance afoot there's
a bad romance Love is a Battlefield very excited
the last thing we watched was Turtles which
we both loved maybe the most can potential
vampires keep up let's find out please like
subscribe hit that notification Bell leave
a comment let us know which of these is your
favorite and if this has vampires because
by them well now the patrons you get this
whole thing the start to finish end to end
and that is a unique experience because it
features our watching faces which you can
only get there and frankly that is well worth
the experience we love those sexy Rejects
and the patreon also I want to say all these
have been fueled by G fuel sometimes off camera
prepping sometimes on camera as of now I know
Greg loves them but I haven't told you guys
how much I love them I love it like without
caffeine I'm nothing but with the wrong caffeine
I crash and I'm worse than nothing can you
feel oh crash just a good time and it's like
zesty energy I'm like this is my Lazarus picture
like it's necessary without the transformation
aspect well it's like a it's like a mental
transformation but I don't have to get all
gooey that's what I'm saying and I do believe
there is a discount code in the box below
the description right discount code it's a
reject Nation yeah save yourself 20 percent
of Select tubs my friend that's a fifth dollar
back every five bucks that's four dollars
back every 20 bucks that's 20 every 100 so
you save some money you save up you be Batman
invest in some stocks
different animation intro every time
Nightwings in the city that's true uh I do
like that the C kind of tells us like a foundational
character black mask mob was kidnapped at
gunpoint by masked assailants earlier today
good diction Saul was a victim of the recent
Turf War composed of high-tech criminals known
to have cost paths with Batman I gave good
diction [Music] big diction [Music] Ary oh
interesting design on him oh Firefly sure
that's when someone lies there's not almost
Rey Winstone in every one of these yep and
yet it's never Ray Winstone what's he doing
being a black widow
[Music]
oh boy right out of his boots Batman doesn't
use guns Batman doesn't cheer that Zack style
oh dang dude cool cool [Music]
let's go Ruby Rose ain't messing around
oh nice I like how our five style is completely
different but like brutal in her own way yeah
the inertia is crazy
nice shot that's no way to treat a lady Jason
O'Mara's back
[Applause]
geez dressing like a bat doesn't make you
a hero it just makes you a Target and using
a gun makes you just like them it's the two
of the enemy Babs you fool that's bad woman
not bad girl stupid stupid
dang pack drones I mean they're pretty effective
against the machinery
[Music] dang
yellow jacket
Corey's still just showing up everything everywhere
Modoc oh I get it acronym I've waited so
and not at all another riddle guy
[Music] did well
just destroy the whole thing for good measure
wowza [Music]
I don't think it's vampires nope I'm gonna
go I don't feel like it's the literal Bad
Blood of like you know relationships like
there's a there's a history it's thematic
Bad Blood yeah not literal not literal Bad
Blood all blood you see on screen is good
blood yeah [Music]
it's not like he punches a Time clock but
I can assure you that the gun news 52 new
52.
I like that coat blood Nightwing Centric At
Last I almost forgotten what you feel like
what's all that noise
that's my night job I think I see an opening
[Music] oh yeah got a family emergency Nightwing
out oh she knows he's nice oh it's like driving
well your trip to the rainforest seems ill-timed
Mr Wayne and I can do whatever the bloody
hell I want to frankly I think we're done
here bring them to Lucius he's more than capable
of handling things while I'm gone deep fake
Alfred wisdom how long has he been gone two
weeks one day 15 hours not that I'm counting
there's already been a sharp uptick in Underworld
activities Oh little Grant Morrison action
disappeared I can't get away from you the
suit so the storyline they teased James Gunn
teased is actually Dick Grayson in the bat
suit I don't think that's what they're gonna
do but that is that run that thing that's
sick I want to read that at very least oh
it's so good if you'd finally accept Mr Wayne's
offer we could do lunch every day dad with
your background in physics and math dad you'd
be an extraordinary asset Exposition Dad I
said no before I went into the service and
it's it is Lucius have Damien and Bruce Wayne's
hairline it's in requirement of all Wayne
employees if you reach certain levels you
gotta have the same [Music] like an Osborne
I'm gonna get those cornrows yeah yeah
[Music]
oh man I thought your doctor told you whiskey
and salad yeah it's like Mama Told Me It's
Your Whiskey are you sure he's dead Kate this
is Batman we're talking about I need your
help on this one two boy please tell me it's
not him I'll see what my network can dig up
on your mystery man [Applause] she cut her
hair since the first scene it's a wig in the
comics because that noise that's one one more
thing to throw off people off the trail
watch your back Kate ah you got this cake
said a wig does seem like it'd be kind of
a liability in a fight I mean that's falling
off pull your cow all over the place Gotham's
my [__]
[Music] let me fix that for you he was dead
he got better
people
had a Ninja Turtle flashback for a second
there it's coming back
[Music]
I have to babysit you again
I could have handled this alone if that's
your best Batman you're not gonna fool anyone
Grayson hahaha dude you gotta pulled double
duty now there's no way you're gonna pull
this off without my help modest as ever I
see some more Batman than you'll ever
you've been tracking me all night first tell
me why you're running around Gotham playing
dress-up I'm guessing Nightwing [Music] just
because I have some respect doesn't mean I'm
a part of your little cult you really have
a way with women Grayson
I mean he does seem to does except when he's
Batman yeah that was that was how women wrecked
Batman so I think he's doing better woman
AKA Catherine Kane Katie she's impressive
but her methods make her a danger to this
city and to herself how do you know her I
just do you're young we're we're talking that's
what the kids say these days they're talking
about Heritage hanging out but who is he all
I know is that he's left a trail of empty
vaults and dead bodies across this city with
all due respect dad that doesn't help much
what am I paying you for Dad I love you as
much as you give me there's some connection
between Wayne Enterprises and Batman I'd say
you supply him with some of his Tech that's
some Theory Dad I just oh [__] Theory
confirmed get us into the Vault Mr Fox or
your son becomes he's not a licensed chiropractor
that we know of that's true that's true everybody
had a job before the job a Goblin glider why
not man probably captured all sorts of strange
Tech in here aside from what they build in-house
yeah yeah so cool use your speeding agility
boy get him
I'm really impressed with all the animated
movies have different set pieces to like mix
up the fighting yeah they're really good at
making them feel different unique each one
yeah yeah like well choreographed interesting
locations and the fighting styles change with
who they're fighting and oh [Music] almost
got his Dick Grayson
classic electrocutioner stop I have a soft
spot for children who you stupid oh
interesting that's an interesting way to see
a boss kill a Hench better than the just like
I need to prove a point real quick take off
mother's pearls where did you get oh oh what
where did you get that jewelry
the hell was this it's that Ayahuasca trip
you're on
hop in there Bruce it's okay oh
oh oh oh God cool
at two dick
it's cool seeing some of the like Grant Morrison
influence uh directly always looks like it
hurts just so much eye stuff
oh Mad Hatter mad Hatton yeah Abraham Lincoln
Abraham Hatter descendant of Lincoln Mad Hatter
everybody knows it threading my way through
the layers you're like wet sand compared to
this concrete it's as if he defines himself
by his pain such Madness push past the trauma
wait a minute is that Tally's back he was
nearly killed but I saved him we should capture
Damien bring him that's brownie points I'm
his new daddy look at me show him this he
will love it weapons that my dad created and
almost got killed I understand I really do
but it's not my call things are complicated
trust me okay nah suit up let's do the John
Ridley run everybody's gotta get a suit the
back community
I wonder how big it is going to be in that
live action take on this you're a cop a detective
you have a problem with that no not at all
you just don't look the part I'm something
of a detective myself not as hot as you did
I just say that out loud yeah you did following
dad's orders I haven't dated in over a year
and I
yeah can I give you my card call me yeah right
I like you but something's come up I love
you based on these 30 seconds we've spoken
like why is it why is exchange information
not enough where's the kid
why'd you say that name Grayson you know when
we were kids and I'd see it all the society
bashes I had quite a crush on you really I
thought you were totally annoying [Laughter]
it's okay Master dick was quite explicit at
least 24 hours of observation he's not my
father and neither were you and for that young
man you should be profoundly grateful
oh boy I don't see Alfred's potential kid
when I got kicked out of the military no shame
in a little Rave sex drugs and techno house
how you doing gorgeous out of my way [__]
I don't think so shave that bat-shaped goatee
right now yeah scumbag
that's my favorite move sometimes you gotta
throw a body at a body
ah
oh Christmas
oh time to suit up oh here we go [Music]
get your own Darth Vader montage [Music] whoa
wow
cyber bat yeah it's Alfred your butler is
a part of this too trust me it's a total badass
yeah watch the prequel show who are you
I'm you Damien huh all grown up what he wanted
to create the perfect Soldier they used your
DNA and put it through a process of accelerated
growth [Music] mother how dare you it wasn't
my idea this lunatic said he killed me if
I shut up I like his Chucks that sucks Comfort
preparedness I've always served you without
question I've never asked anything of you
mommy how could I not have felt the depths
of your pain How could a mother have left
her child so alone in the dark ugh wow [Laughter]
you have no use to me like this for calcitrant
emotional your father's influence no doubt
Onyx get this trash out of here take out the
trash Tyler is a boss
guns and Guns it's a whole sub-genre of movie
this whole sequence directed by Robert Rodriguez
none exploitation
running like just but they're nuns they're
not just not just with gun just why are they
in the live action movies is what I want to
know James Gunn adapt this directly James
none James Nunn with the gun ninja nuns bar
son [Music]
you're shooting nuns they're shooting yeah
what else you want come on this is every Catholic
school kids fantasy oh 100
mama oh [Music] it is a fatal flaw
sweet slow nurse
battling that's original
Batman there's a template there's a name generator
it's like how childish Gambino got it you
gotta plug it in you gotta see what's log
into the bat General what's available even
relax dude Matt Ludwig gordonson last night
racing whoa imagine him scoring a bat oh dude
dude
[Music] and we'll just leave these highly
valuable prisoners here chilling
see you got a little circus in you oh yeah
oh
iron bat yeah the parallels are in Batman
and Iron Man weren't strong enough
for you guys this is what he is
smack him again you know you wanna yep yep
yep it is [Music] God's Not Gonna like this
I don't think she's been here for a while
oh yeah
it has like almost any Gordo
oh yeah come on come on
got a little Indiana Jones yes how are you
how are you I'm Batman that's all I had to
say how are you I'm Batman he's Batman [Music]
you harm one hair on her weave
yeah gratifying thing they get to do ah just
Glide silhouetted what do you do when it's
not a full moon though dramatic lighting find
a way yeah Street Lamp oh kiddo you're about
about a little there gonna pull your top half
apart [Music] I hope Bruce fights the rest
of his this movie in his underwear sometimes
you gotta box boxers and you know they're
specially designed bat under oh 100 logo all
up in them yeah little utility belt
toothpaste floss for nights four Dark Knights
too bad they got away dad always wanted me
to work with Bruce Wayne we can handle this
on our own Robin such a big help I'm also
that's not true because you'd be dead you
really should be resting the summit's tomorrow
it's been a week I'm fine I gotta fight with
Superman tonight
Bruce Wayne arrived to deliver the keynote
address that will kick off the conference
and also unveil groundbreaking technological
advances researchers wow nice place what a
home find anything on that hard drive yet
no I gave it to Batwing nothing to be sorry
about goodbye dick just like that no more
Batwoman kicked out of the bat family
oh damn it
now the question is has he been brain jacked
yep he looks pretty vacant tied
I'll take a 50 on calling that [Music] oh
yeah
yeah yeah I was gonna say I had to hurt more
than a regular knife a man of peace Mr Bruce
Wayne that's what I think of when I think
of Bruce Wayne kindness taking people out
of the family left and right so kind with
these translators we hope to build Bridges
between language and culture
Wayne Tech and Star Labs have developed the
Watchtower initiative on the greatest adventure
oh oh my Batman Inc Eye in the Sky
[Music]
yeah I was gonna say you're unveiling your
flying surveillance station while you got
these guys on the loose not great I want a
mobile office is out of a suitcase and all
the leaders she would need are at the summit
of course they are Swain
Dick's got a great hairdo it's like an almost
mullet which I respect yeah it's got that
Jared Padalecki hair yeah oh
not Alfred you don't punch Alfred I don't
care who you are so many Minds so little time
and a new age dog
hey babbling need a ride in me
beautiful sky good thing you got us those
schematics but my dad understands when he
finds out I hacked his computer yeah he'll
be fine it's what he's always wanted you're
in the family business now yeah oh nice that's
awesome
[Music]
oh
blatant memory Bruce betray Batman we've got
to find the dignitaries and evacuate them
our first priority is getting those people
out they've been so loyal I know from where
he's come from to here yeah I mean he doesn't
really care about lives but still loves Bruce
Bruce's life that's a start join us or die
philosophy never pays off
got him by the tusks
there is no you you have no hoe you have no
people there is only Zuul I mean Alfred's
just too ready at all times he's he's gonna
take care of him he's Batman's butler all
right the glue
guns on guns gunfu
yep let's do this let's go [Music]
[Music]
it's like you're seeing stars for a hot second
there
[Music] I just love that they went Ham on
the sky they're about it pretty little Crayola
action most beautiful magic hour fight you've
ever seen it's a full hour magic hour yep
yeah don't fight me on a Star Wars set again
yeah you are fighting on them thing in the
sky going into Gotham no good and it just
takes off right in the direction of the city
the Voyages of the USS Enterprise Alfred
jeez it's like fist is the the size of Damien
yep oh
a full evolution of his Arc Vengeance Justice
not Vengeance my guy well done yeah damn you're
trying got a situation yeah you had the right
idea you passed anyway yeah yeah fight interrupted
by building well [__]
like that Luger too she's got pretty awful
Point play game with it because she does she
does it's that German engineering [Music]
ah damn it selfish yeah and my sixth training
don't pick up penny worth come on take you
out 11 times out of ten oh blue is mine oh
oh you've got a clock worked
bloody hell [Music] that's what a decapitation
looks like it's his head exploded to like
all of him explodes I couldn't quite tell
but it doesn't leave an empty suit
I did not think we'll see Mad Hatter in another
one of these no no a little surprised in fact
it seems like kind of a notable Village yeah
no not anymore
and Foster for Mad Hatter oh good car right
we need some Ben faster
[Music] God [Music] come on Gundam bat [Music]
oh
[Music] getting tired that dead arm come on
dick
well done beloved we will at least victory
oh where's the programming finish him
tool the enemy it's all about [Music] you've
never killed don't let her take your soul
like how it's Nightwing's weapon and her weapon
we needed family we needed you shoot him you're
not just a mask you're a man a masked man
I like how much I hate seeing Batman in the
gun that like this they conveyed that wrongness
like it yeah oh oh dude for the little boy
who lost his world in that alley enough
oh that look on his face I'm sorry I'm okay
so sorry [Music]
that's for what you did to my father [__]
[__] I have thought of little else for
the last 12 years not the death of my father
not even our child could bring you to my side
you left yeah you done [__] up you're
pissed out you're brainwashed let me try to
kill your kid you did you messed up
[Music]
yeah flying trash compactor it was ready the
whole time on loan from the Ewoks or the sand
people you know sand people yeah hmm
tuscans Tuscan Raiders that's right no in
fact the correct answer was Jawas oh
him fighting oh and that's the last we'll
see of Talia and Onyx and killed off screen
yeah hit the water charged with nitroglycerin
I don't know what happened there but it happened
it's a tribute to The Dark Knight Rises where
he takes the news well I suppose touch could
have done it I'm proud of you Kate Gabrielle
and Elizabeth would be proud to just wrap
your head of the concussion so you do yeah
I guess so you know just recite your birthday
and your address and you're right on time
cute damn just skipping straight to lunch
with the parents yeah she really did like
a good drink [Music] I'm mad I assume you're
my son
I recognize that chin he was more saluting
just to the tech despite her Madness she was
his mother turtle legs are back very happy
about it oh the turtlenecks it's the good
Sally needs like a little change yeah [Music]
bad blood not a vampire movie I want a vampire
Batman movie that's what I want outro Montage
bitchin cool I'm gonna come together as a
family of their different vehicles yeah they
do yes quarter mile at a time there they go
that's right that's right race for pig slips
[Music] it's like Nightwing's a tuner guy
Batman's an American muscle guy sure yeah
100 yeah Gotham SS or something like that
or like an old Camaro yeah
[Music] all right the five of us let's go
get the penguin in a car that's right this
isn't excessive this is not Overkill there's
not other crime we could divide and conquer
more efficiently
it's good big family ah cool I like the ending
so this is the official moment that taught
me then that if you see the black with the
red it's Kate Kate if you see purple with
the yellow it's Babs woman girl woman also
jmd uh de matteus wrote this as well comic
writer like last time that's exciting ah nice
all right hell yeah he's a guy that wrote
a lot of like uh Ben Reilly Spider-Man stuff
he was a Marvel guy back in the 90s Ben Reilly
uh Scarlet Spider the clone of Spider-Man
one of my favorite characters of all time
oh dude I got a I'm a clone saga Defender
I'm one of the few I got us I gotta check
it out I gotta see if I agree I uh people
hate the clone saga but I think Ivan straw
hofsky was that woman interested we're gonna
back her in his back yeah John DiMaggio a
little bit a little bit okay Travis Willingham
hell yeah it's a good voice cast yeah it was
solid I gotta peep I want to make sure is
there a post credit guys I'm trying to drink
a gallon a day it's not easy so okay you're
doing so great I just you know it's a full
full movie future links I just don't want
to spin the reviews spinning in my chair prancing
no I don't believe there is sweet freedom
all right all righty oh so that is probably
like the most connected uh one we've had bat
specific but also maybe the most connected
we're gonna have to what James Gunn's doing
sure okay because uh Grant Morrison run is
uh kicks off with Nightwing in the Batman
tool okay so there's a lot of correlation
there which would be interesting to see if
Italian uh where is Bruce and all of this
I mean he is presumed dead in in the book
so uh I don't know if they'd want like just
because they showed the cover of that comic
doesn't mean like it wasn't like the super
girl announcement where they were like we're
doing this like this yeah it's this run it's
more it's like it's inspired by this take
but I don't know if you'd want to start a
Batman without Batman but it'd be kind of
fun to be like like if the people know Batman
enough the hunt for Batman could be fun yeah
like the mystery of Batman yeah and I think
that would be create a new way to build excitement
towards the new Batman in a different way
that's not just about people who paid attention
to movie news waiting for a cast again yes
you know yes and also like introducing the
bat family as like a family already established
would be interesting to do yeah like they
did here because I think we are at a point
now where you know the culture knows Batman
well enough that I think you can start to
screw around with who's in the cowl and right
and the different Associates who are going
to pop up frequently and it would give Nightwing
some time in the sun which everyone wants
I feel like that Wing's been like way overdue
I was gonna say aren't they is that Nightwing
movie they were trying to do is that the Christmas
there's a Christmas cake yeah I mean that's
been in development for like 10 years okay
so I don't know so that's in limbo and will
likely be repurposed as as they kick off the
new DC and maybe they'll use some of it like
maybe they'll then you know do a Nightwing
with it okay but we'll see um I liked it didn't
love it yeah to me this was one of the ones
where uh it's kind of in the middle like it's
solid I had a lot of fun it felt more like
an episode of a show than yeah most of the
other movies have I agree with that felt more
like you know just kind of one in many ongoing
Adventures maybe like a special episode because
you think Bruce is gone but yeah it kind of
moved and and felt like something out of a
series yeah it was nice to be cohesive uh
like it was nice to feel that Damien connection
it's nice to see him evolve and grow all those
things were good um but I definitely like
found myself not distracted but like not as
intensely riveted not as gripped yeah and
I don't know why like there's no real direct
reason but like it was good I'd give it like
a b whereas I just think that Turtles was
like such an a it's well yeah because that
one just fires on all the things you want
for fun but then it goes harder on the things
that they don't have to focus as heavily on
like they made that an actual movie and they
bothered to like really fast yeah that's right
the tones together and the worlds together
and they really kind of smartly created that
Harmony whereas whereas here you know uh this
was I feel like a little slight on certain
detail that was like the whole thing with
um what do we call him again you know the
big clone bat heretic there you go uh like
that's a really cool looking character really
cool concept of a character and I feel like
once we got the reveal of heretic it was kind
of like and he's done bye-bye it felt more
like he just existed ultimately to feel these
clones yeah for the Betrayal and to reveal
that she's got you know Damien's genetic material
on hand to just like keep perfecting the perfect
Soldier or whatever but I felt like there
could have been like an emotional punch to
that rather than just like oh man this is
this big bad who somehow managed to yeah to
take Batman hostage and he's got his image
and and it just seemed like there was so much
there's a lot more Nuance that could have
been used with that yeah it's like the appearance
suggests it it's like oh man this is really
pointed this is clearly I I thought it was
gonna have something to do with them trying
to tarnish the Batman's reputation because
this guy does so much resemble him but in
more of a gladiatorial kind of way and then
yell the whole you know cloning and this even
the mirroring of like bat family to the likeness
of you they didn't really lean into like the
fact that in the movie that introduces him
he's forming a family and like the Betrayal
of self and like the lack of like you know
Batman holding a gun is him fighting against
all his instincts and then like you know that
villain kind of represents the way Jamie and
lost fighting those instincts like they could
have paralleled those things you know there
was just a couple opportunities that would
have been nice to go deeper yeah absolutely
and and two I feel like um that is a great
shot though when he's got oh man it's so intense
and the stick and like you know there's a
lot like Alfred's always great Nightwing is
always great I even I like their Damien a
lot here I know people go back and forth on
Damien I think he works here yeah uh Bruce
the thing is too it's like having Bruce be
out of commission and kidnapped like I liked
I thought the best stuff was the focus they
gave to Kate and Dick and and Damien and Alfred
all that stuff was pretty good and then the
rest of it also felt like what am I trying
to say it seemed like having Bruce taken out
of commission and put through this like mental
rigor of them like searching his mind and
and stuff like I thought that also could have
been a little just more Hefty that one scene
was great I would love to see more of that
yeah because like that's a struggle like I
feel like we didn't we get the moment at the
end where he has the struggle you know with
the weapons and everything and that is cathartic
but I thought I don't know like maybe show
us some of that talk he has with Damien you
know more so or or more of it you know we
get a little bit of it but but yeah like something
about this it for how episodic it kind of
feels this one yeah it seems weird to have
such a tumultuous circumstance as Batman being
decommissioned and kidnapped and you know
experimented upon so I in a weird way it felt
like there wasn't as much like of that heft
or that kind of like dark when they go for
these things a lot of the time it's called
Bad Blood and like that's you know dealing
with you know Damien being cloned as dealing
with like their history it's dealing with
all those things but that was all the stuff
they like kind of breezed out not breezed
over but they could have dove into the title
earned yeah especially for one of the slider
movies too in terms of yeah I mean run time
very short I mean Talia like I did kind of
feel like thinking back on the continuity
It's Like Son of Batman she takes off like
there is I believe a little conversation at
the end about you know perhaps kind of both
being involved with Damien yeah there was
almost like a neutrality and that was the
last time we saw her and then she was also
like there was a love for Damien that wasn't
a parent here yeah and then she's like ah
you know like because you all made it impossible
I'm not like no you just you got on your boats
we all agree we were sharing custody we were
sharing custody now you come back with clones
and you think I'm the problem yeah it's like
you chose this and when did this happen he
was gone for like a year yeah he was still
monkeys like he was like she she said 12 years
ago I think we met him when he was 10. so
two years at most have gone by sure that is
accelerated clothing yes yeah so like things
like that are are you know it adds up but
still an enjoyable time still a b still funny
still fun still well choreographed still action-packed
entertaining still a great adaptation um but
you know there's some that are just exceptional
and this was good yeah yeah I'll put this
in the decent yeah yeah not bad time a lot
of fun badass moments and stuff a lot of fun
Rogues it was nice to see like Firefly on
screen and stuff like that yeah I love Mad
Hatter again Ben Foster Castle uh but yeah
I'm really curious how they adapt this live
action if this is the story they choose to
tell uh really curious about you know the
the next step in the bat family after this
because Damian is you know Justice not Vengeance
like it's really cool to see that um I love
the direct commentary I remember one of the
things I was bothered by with Justice League
War was the the the characterization of Wonder
Woman and Superman but I do love this characterization
of Batman this is in that same universe so
it's nice to see a Batman that is staunchly
no guns to the point of it being a plot point
I'm enjoying those elements so um and that
doesn't feel any less gritty and and like
you know yeah the whole no guns thing doesn't
hamper any of the bones it's not a weapon
he would use it's the weapon of the coward
yeah and the way he uses it finally I was
like cool yeah uses it to deflect a different
weapon nice like you know and it doesn't feel
like anything is lost by putting emphasis
on that yeah I agree yeah so good not great
uh but very much enjoy this is a B for me
personally quick question batwing yep what
how how rich is the history across so I've
actually got a tricky thing with batwing because
to me bat wing is one of those like power
set characters where it's like well then like
if you're Iron Man that undermines all the
bat like as soon as you introduce Tech but
he's good at math they've said it I could
but like so as soon as you introduce him it's
like why is he chasing penguin like it it
really affects the whole as soon as Iron Man's
fighting alongside Nightwing and Batman and
all that stuff it makes them all very you
know it seems like batwing should be in Space
the power structure really shifts um so he's
got a history I just it's never a character
I've really enjoyed my bat family that I enjoy
are all street level like I like when it's
you know the characters that have to stay
on the ground because because then that's
the charm of Batman joining with the Justice
League right because that's that's that heart
so like he's got history it's just not I mean
to me Batman Beyond is the only time I like
Batman in Tech because it's in the future
and that's what he has to do to keep up so
you know Batman Bruce Wayne designs a suit
to keep up with the modern day criminals because
he's getting older Terry McGinnis you know
needs that to keep up so like if you've gotta
attack Batman in the modern day it doesn't
really seem you've got like half Batman half
cyborg or something like yeah it's just not
a character I personally like it's a little
overpower he also learned how to [__]
do that soon like 30 minutes you just put
it on it's like good thing I got these skills
Lucius made a very easy to follow instructional
video he just did a lot of video game automatics
where he's like and this is how you do this
this way press X and Y to fire batarang so
it's not a character I've read a lot but he
pops up a decent amount um and there's tons
of bad family there's even more than that
but I'm always more on the side of uh you
know Batgirl Batwoman Nightwing Robin yeah
that's my world that makes sense uh except
to see what's next we don't know I mean it's
always a mystery we don't even know if
I mean that was a moment and there is some
really beautiful animation across like and
especially when they do those establishing
shots of like the monastery and things like
the longest Convent I should say yeah the
lock is golden hour in history but that was
the power of the nunnery yeah more Nuns with
guns I mean nudges should be just James Gunn
how it's time how has there not been a character
who's a nun who exclusively uses nunchucks
oh call it none chaku the movie are there
any actors Chuck Norris is very old but are
there any actors named Chuck that could team
up with a nun and then you've got non-shocks
anyone named Charles besides Xavier there's
got to be an actor named Charles Martin That's
the voice of Mario Charles
this is good writes itself it writes you're
welcome Hollywood you know after cocaine bear
nunchucks Universal we're available to write
nunchuck oh I'm on the script already who
do we got we got uh uh Rosario Dawson oh Charlie
Day definitely not a truck nunchuck Rosary
I want to see it yeah we'll then see the opportunity
becomes you know you can cast like some heavyweighters
like Mother Superior like like Salma Hayek
or somebody or who's a who's uh like Carla
Gugino Carla Gugino is the ultimate nun yeah
Rosario she could kick an ass and then Rosario
Dawson's like the main one jump you into the
world Charlie day is just overwhelmed and
squeaky and excited but he's Chuck yeah none
shot guys we're here all week we're here every
day we'll be back next week with uh the nunchucks
equal again we don't know what it is yet but
let us know in the comments what you enjoyed
the most of this watch what you'd like us
to watch next what of these where do you rank
this in your scale and we are thinking at
the end of this Grand Journey 40 in 50 and
who knows how many movies in we're gonna rank
them John on uncoi's comic corner and we're
gonna make a list and we'll have a list of
we'll have like a like a final four I'm excited
to see if there are any ones we will I want
to get in into a tussle over at least one
yeah it's gonna be weird [Music]
yeah and even even from our different degrees
of like comic knowledge which I feel like
we're still able to kind of meet in the middle
so contestants how good they are yeah like
you know my having read the Social Security
and you haven't but you having knowledge of
the characters that shows how adaptable absolutely
well that is a good place to end at your lovelies
thank you for watching we'll see you soon
like subscribe all those things comments YouTube
it all and stay hydrated so you have to Pete
right at the very end you'll see that in the
edit all right bye guys
uh you haven't seen this no I've never seen
any of these coins every time it's good it's
good you gotta keep me on because I'm saying
it's the first time to you this is the first
one we're gonna get 20 into this you're like
no I've seen this one I'd be like John this
is suddenly all familiar this is weird I've
seen Batman versus Turtles 72. but I haven't
seen the rest of them I haven't seen that
hasn't seen them [Music]